Welcome to English in a Minute,...
...where we teach you all about idioms in American English.
If you have ever heard American English, you might have heard this.
Hit the sack.
What does this mean?
Let's find out by listening to this conversation.
I'm exhausted and can't stay up another minute.
I'm gonna go hit the sack.
I probably should do the same, it's been a long day.
It sounds like they are tired and ready to sleep.
That's what "hit the sack" means; you are going to bed.
During World War II, American soldiers called their sleeping bags "sacks".
So, "hit the sack" meant "to go to bed".
Today, people use this phrase all the time.
Hit the sack.
And that's English in a Minute.